the Golden Age of Indian chess and it's
all because of one man vishwanathan
Anand today we are outside the home of
Aruna and vision and to get a peek into
their life let's go
Hi how are you it's lovely to see you
thank you
[Music]
yeah hi Haroon
is this the famous room where when India
has a new Grand Master there's a
tradition that we've heard about he's
invited to your home is this where
it happens yes we obviously they're
allowed to sit there as well but
invariably they want to come in and have
a look and then pictures of Prague
coming go fish coming
conversations that happen here with the
young kids usually we get very quickly
many of them are tongue-tied so we
usually we get very quickly to why don't
you show me your last game man then they
open up a lot